supongamos que estoy tratando de evaluar
cuántos años de experiencia tenemos en
la academia kahn cuántos años de
experiencia tenemos en promedio y el
tipo de promedio que voy a enfocar en
particular es la media aritmética así es
que voy encuestó a los compañeros
supongamos que esto es cuando la
academia kahn era pequeña cuando tan
solo había cinco personas en la
organización y encuentro esto
encuestando a toda la población
encuentro que los años de experiencia de
la población total de la academia kahn
eso es lo que me interesa
así que años de experiencia en nuestra
organización en la academia kahn eso es
lo que nos interesa esto es cuando
éramos cinco personas en la academia
kahn ahora somos 36 personas pero no
quiero que importe la fecha de este
vídeo
así es que checo llegue una persona que
acabe salir de la universidad ese es un
año de experiencia otra persona que
tiene 3 años de experiencia otra persona
que tiene 5 años de experiencia una
persona de 7 años de experiencia y
alguien muy experimentado con 14 años de
experiencia así es que basados en este
conjunto de datos y esta sería nuestra
población para años de experiencia estoy
suponiendo que sólo hay 5 personas en la
organización en este momento cuál sería
la media poblacional para años
experiencia cuál es la media aritmética
para estos datos que son los años de
experiencia de mi población bueno vamos
a calcular la la media mío y estoy
usando la letra griega a mí porque estoy
refiriéndome a la población estoy
refiriéndome al parámetro poblacional
esta media es igual a la suma la suma
desde el primer dato hasta el enésimo
dato de una vez pongo que n es igual a 5
son 5 datos los que tenemos así es que
vamos a tener la suma desde igual a 1
hasta 5 de cada uno de mis xy datos esto
es igual
x 1 más esto por supuesto dividido entre
5 más x 2 más x 3 más x 4 más x 5
dividido entre
5 y como hemos dicho esta es una manera
muy elegante indicar que voy a sumar
todas estas cosas voy a sumar todos mis
datos y luego dividir entre el número de
datos que en este caso es igual a 5
hagamos eso sacó la calculadora y vamos
vamos a ver los datos aquí podemos ver
bien los datos tenemos que es uno más
tres más cinco más siete más catorce y
esto
dividido entre 5 y esto nos da un total
de 6 la media poblacional para años de
experiencia en mi organización es igual
a 66 años de experiencia bien creo que
esto es interesante pero ahora quiero
hacer otra pregunta quiero obtener una
medida de que tanto varían estos datos
con respecto a la media que tanto se
dispersan con respecto a la media de los
datos obviamente podría darle a alguien
todos estos datos pero más bien lo que
quiero es obtener un parámetro que de
alguna manera represente que tanto
varían estos números en promedio con
respecto a la media poblacional este
número que tenemos aquí y cómo quiero
medir la variación le llamaré a dicho
número la varianza
varianza variance aclarando que esto es
la varianza de la población es un
parámetro la varianza poblacional y la
voy a denotar por la letra sigma
minúscula está aquí en la cima mayúscula
pero esta es sigma minúscula al cuadrado
y lo que voy a hacer es tomar la
distancia de cada uno de estos datos con
respecto a la media la voy a elevar al
cuadrado para tener un valor positivo y
la voy a dividir entre el número de
datos que tenemos básicamente lo que
vamos a encontrar es el promedio de la
distancia al cuadrado suena un poco
complicado pero calculemos lo así que
tomo mi primer dato tomo mi primer dato
y le restó el valor de la media y lo
elevó al cuadrado
este número es negativo pero el elevado
al cuadrado lo hacemos positivo esto es
básicamente la distancia de uno a la
media elevada al cuadrado ya eso le voy
a sumar la distancia al cuadrado entre
el 3 y la media
y a eso le voy a agregar la distancia al
cuadrado entre el 5 y la media y no
importa que esto sea negativo a la
elevarlo al cuadrado es positivo 5 6 ó 6
menos cinco no hace ninguna diferencia
al elevarlo al cuadrado a eso le voy a
sumar la distancia entre el 7 y la media
elevado al cuadrado y notemos que
estamos hablando de la distancia con
respecto a la media poblacional
finalmente a esto le voy a sumar la
distancia entre 14 y la media
poblacional
ahí están 7 14 y 6 que es la media
población elevada al cuadrado y luego
voy a tomar el promedio de estas
distancias elevadas al cuadrado es decir
voy a dividir toda esta suma entre el
número total de datos que es 5 y que
obtenemos al hacer la suma de estas
distancias al cuadrado bueno calculemos
lo aquí abajo esto va a ser igual
165 elevado al cuadrado es 25 más 36 63
elevado al cuadrado es 9 positivo esto
más 56 es menos 1 elevado al cuadrado es
uno más
7 menos seis es 1 al cuadrado es 1 ya
esto finalmente le sumamos 14 menos 68
elevado al cuadrado es igual a 64
dividimos entonces todo esto lo
dividimos entre 5 y esto cuánto va a ser
igual sacó la calculadora no podía ser
mentalmente pero tiene equivocarme mucho
cuando lo hago mentalmente esto es igual
a 25 más 9 más uno más uno más 64
todo esto dividido entre 5 esto nos da
igual a 20 así que el promedio la
distancia al cuadrado o la media de la
distancia al cuadrado con respecto a la
media poblacional es igual a 20 es igual
a 20 y tú podrías decir bueno un momento
ninguno de estos valores es 20 pero
acuérdate calculamos la distancia al
cuadro con respecto a esta media
poblacional
cada uno de estos términos y eso estuvo
bien porque los hicimos positivos
posteriormente veremos que esto tiene
otras propiedades interesantes
finalmente como representamos esto
matemáticamente ya sabemos que aquí se
representa la media poblacional también
sabemos cómo representar matemáticamente
la media de la muestra espero que la
anotación ya no te resulte oscura pero
como representamos matemáticamente la
varianza poblacional que acabamos de
calcular establezcamos entonces que para
la varianza poblacional hemos tomado la
suma hemos tomado la suma para todos los
datos desde el primer dato hasta el
enésimo dato de nuestra población
este es un parámetro poblacional de
nuestro dato pero no tan sólo vamos a
sumar los datos sino a cada uno de
nuestros datos le vamos a restar la
media poblacional vamos a restarle esto
de aquí vamos a restarle esto de aquí y
lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado
lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado y si te
fijas aquí sólo estoy expresando el
numerador está
el numerador la suma de cada una de las
diferencias de los valores con respecto
a la media elevado al cuadrado para
obtener lo que calculamos aquí lo que
tengo que hacer es dividir toda esta
suma entre el número de datos que
tenemos y esta fórmula que se ve tan fea
e intimidante lo único que dice es toma
tus datos resta le bueno no primero
primero calcula la media poblacional
calcula la media poblacional a cada uno
de los valores de la población
préstale el valor de la media
poblacional
luego eleva al cuadrado la diferencia
suma todos esos valores y luego
simplemente divide por el número de
datos que tienes y vas a obtener la
varianza poblacional